[TITLE MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF JOHNSON: Welcome
to day three of Next.
I am so excited to see
so many people here.
Days one and two have
been action-packed.
I don't know about you,
but I drank probably
about a pot of
coffee this morning,
so I am rip-roaring
and ready to go.
My name is Jeff Johnson.
I'm a software engineer on
the GKE team in Seattle.
TINA ZHANG: And I'm Tina Zhang.
I'm a site reliability engineer
for GKE, based in London.
JEFF JOHNSON: Today
we're going to talk
to you about delivering
high-availability clusters
on GKE.
This talk isn't going to
go into a lot of details
about what Kubernetes is.
We're sort of expecting you to
bring some of that experience
in maybe you've used Kubernetes
on GKE, maybe otherwise.
But what we want to do is
dive into some of the details
on how we deploy Kubernetes,
how we manage it.
Tina's going to talk to you
about how SRE keeps clusters
healthy, and what I want to do
is share some best practices
in taking an
application and making
it resilient to zonal failure.
So let's start with the K. If
you have been around GCP Next
this week, you've probably heard
this word a few hundred times
now, so this slide may
be a little irrelevant,
but Kubernetes is an open
source container orchestration
framework, originally
built by Google,
and now in the open
source community.
It is based off our
experience running containers
at scale with Borg.
Kubernetes can run on
any infrastructure.
It can run in the cloud
as a hosted offering.
It could run on-prem.
But the important thing
to know for today's talk
is that Kubernetes is all
about managing applications,
not infrastructure.
GKE is, of course,
Google Kubernetes engine.
It's a mature product
that has been generally
available for three years
now, although to be honest,
I think it's three years
and, like, a month,
but to the significant digit,
I think that's pretty good.
If you're interested
in following GKE--
our updates, tips, and tricks,
I recommend checking out
the Google Cloud Platform blog.
So with a little bit of
that product background,
Tina is going to talk
to you more about GCP.
TINA ZHANG: Thanks, Jeff.
So let's say you've
decided that GKE
is the right solution
for your workloads,
a next key decision that will
influence the reliability
and availability
of your application
is how you deploy your GKE
cluster across GCP locations.
So at the moment
you have a choice
of 17 regions and
52 zones, and these
are expanding all the time.
So regions are independent
geographic areas, or loosely
speaking, a campus of data
centers that consist of zones,
and a zone is a deployment area
for cloud platform resources
within a region.
So between zones
of the same region
you have high-bandwidth,
low-latency network connections
that you can typically expect
less than the millisecond,
in the 95th percentile.
And from an availability
point of view,
zones should be considered
a single point of failure--
the points of failure
domain within a region.
Let's take a look at
how that works in GKE.
So the most basic deployment
is what we call a zonal cluster
deployment, like
the one pictured
here, where you have a single
master along with nodes,
all in the same zone.
And when you run a
Kubernetes cluster on GKE,
we host the master VM in
our own Google project,
and you create work
nodes in your project.
So in this mode
Kubernetes will mitigate
against individual
machine failures,
but in the event of a zonal
failure such as an asteroid
striking a data center, the
entire cluster will go down.
So in order to deploy
fault-tolerant applications
with high availability, you
should deploy your applications
across multiple
zones in a region
in order to help protect against
this single point of failure,
and that's what we call a
multi-zonal node deployment.
So in this configuration GKE
will distribute your work nodes
across multiple zones
within the same region,
though you have to have at
least one node in the same zone
as your master, and you cannot
deploy nodes in a completely
separate region.
And if you are using
cluster auto-scaler
and your cluster
contains node pools that
have the same instance
type, cluster scaler
will try to keep those node
pool sizes balanced for you
when scaling up in
order to prevent
against uneven distribution
of node pool sizes
across multiple zones.
So this means that an asteroid
strike in a single zone
won't take down
your entire cluster.
And Jeff is going to
describe those failure
modes in more detail.
JEFF JOHNSON: So let's look
at a typical application
deployed on GKE.
So if we look at
this diagram, we
have that hosted master
node, in US-central1-f,
and that's in the Google Manage
project, so its actually a bit
opaque to you as a
user of GKE, but its
important to know what's there.
And we have our nodes
across three zones,
so each one of those green
boxes maps to a GCE VM.
These little yellow
checkered boxes above,
that's representing your
application workload.
So in this case, we
have a deployment,
we have asked them for three
replicas of that deployment,
and Kubernetes has chosen to
spread them across these zones.
So what happens when
that asteroid strikes?
So we've lost our VMs.
They are offline,
cannot be reached.
But we've maintained the
other set of machines.
The other two failure domains
there are happy and healthy,
so they're able to
continue to serve traffic.
Instances that are
running on those machines
are going to be unaffected,
by the Kubernetes
master is regularly
pooling and looking
at the state of the world,
and will make the decision
to schedule a new pot.
You know, it expects
three, it sees two,
so it'll create a second.
So in that case, we get
our application back,
everything is happy.
But you know, this
is the lucky case.
We were fortunate that
the zone that went down,
the zone that we
had an issue with,
happened to not be the
zone our master node is in.
So what happens if that
master node goes down?
So in this case, we still
have those running workloads.
They still are remaining
on those healthy nodes,
and Kubernetes is
designed to sit in this
as sort of a steady state.
The nodes won't
affect the workloads.
They're only waiting
to be told what to do,
but they don't have
anything new to do,
so they'll sort of
remain in that mode.
Traffic can continue to
enter the [? D ?] cluster,
so if you're using the
global load balancer,
it's doing health checks
on those down nodes,
and won't route traffic to them.
However where you will
experience a problem
is when you have
internal services.
So if you have an internal
Kubernetes service that
is in that downed node over
there-- that downed zone,
the internal services may still
try to route to that machine.
And that's because the control
plane and the master node
are responsible for
registering the endpoints that
tell the services where to go.
When I want to
connect to Redis, it
tells me, OK, this is a hop that
you can go to that's available.
And without the
control plane up, I'm
going to have a
stale set of routes.
So we see how a single
node can be problematic,
and can result in this state.
But Tina is going to
talk to you about how
we want to solve some of that.
TINA ZHANG: OK, so
in order to eliminate
the single point of failure
that Jeff just described,
you can use a GKE
regional cluster,
which is a product that became
generally available in June.
And with a regional cluster
you get a multi-master setup
where there are three masters
in three different zones
within a GCP region.
So we have a load
balancer that's
sitting in front
of these masters,
and that serves as
the endpoint that's
used to communicate
with the control plane.
And by having three masters
behind your GKE cluster,
we help to eliminate downtime
when one master becomes
unavailable, either because it's
become into an unhealthy state,
or because it's being upgraded.
So when we perform
upgrades of the master,
we upgrade one at a time so
you don't get the downtime
that you would experience with
a zonal cluster deployment.
And then when it
comes to the nodes,
you could still choose to have
all of your nodes singly homed
within one region--
sorry, within one
zone, or you can
use the multi-zonal
deployment that's shone
here, which works much
the same as before.
But of course ultimately, if
you have a multi-master setup
and a multi-zonal
deployment, that
doesn't automatically
mean that your application
is high-availability.
JEFF JOHNSON: So that
begs the question, what
does high availability mean?
I think when we talk
high availability,
a lot of times we jump
towards solutions.
We talk about putting
load balancers,
and things like that-- failover.
But simply put,
high availability
means meeting some high SLO.
In practice, that's
some number of nines
that meets your business needs.
And really there's many
ways to achieve HA.
You could have, for instance,
a highly-available network
connection that
you buy from an ISP
because they gave you a
dedicated circuit that
has an extremely high SLO.
Or you could buy internet
from a couple of providers
and perform failover
between them.
When you're designing your
application to meet a high SLO,
it's important that you
understand all the pieces that
make up that application,
and can understand where
all the failures can happen.
One way to split that up-- and I
think this works well for a lot
of applications, but we'll say
in the context of Kubernetes
--is to break it up
into these four layers--
the control plane, the
networking, the application,
and the persistence
underneath all that.
We saw how a single
zone cluster on GKE
could go down with a zone, and
the failures that can happen.
So it's clearly not a
high-availability solution.
But as cluster
administrators it's
our responsibility to
ensure that our cluster--
our control plane
--is running in a way
that supports that failover.
Tina is going to dive into some
of those pieces of the control
plane-- into the
Kubernetes internals
--to talk about
how we manage that.
TINA ZHANG: OK, so taking
a closer look at what's
happening with the
components on the masters
when you're running a
GKE regional cluster.
So here we're going to
show you how they interact
with each other in
order to deliver
this high-availability
control plane.
So to start off, when it
comes to the API server,
these all work in active mode.
So all the API
servers are actively
doing the work that's being
assigned to them by the load
balancer, and this is possible
because the API server
is a stateless component.
So it doesn't matter which
individual API server
is receiving the request.
But they only talk to
their local etcd's.
But when it comes
to etcd, things
are a little bit more complex.
So a group of etcd
instances together
is called an etcd cluster.
And because etcd is a
distributed key value
store that's backed
by a database,
there needs to be
leader election
with a strict majority in order
for writes to the database
to succeed.
You might ask why here there
are actually two etcd clusters.
This is because there
is a core etcd that
has the main
Kubernetes objects that
influence the functionality and
the operations of the cluster--
that's etcd-0.
And then there's a
separate etcd-1 cluster
that's used just for
storing Kubernetes events.
So these events objects
are providing an insight
into what's happening inside
the cluster, such as a pod
re-scheduling, or
a pod eviction,
but they're not fundamental to
the functioning of the cluster,
and you can imagine
that they are probably
be quite high in
number, so we keep them
in a separate etcd
cluster for that reason.
And I want to spend a
little bit of time delving
into why we have three
masters for regional clusters,
and not two or four.
And this is all related to how
etcd reaches Quorum in order
to write to the database.
So for writes to succeed
you need a strict majority,
so, i.e., two out of three
must reach agreement.
And with three
masters that means
you can tolerate the
failure of one master,
because the remaining two
healthy instances are still
able to reach Quorum, so it
guarantees that there'll still
be a majority of the cluster
that can continue to operate.
However, if we only
had two masters,
you would still
need both members
to be healthy to reach
this strict majority,
so you wouldn't have any
failover in that case.
So it's worth
noting that actually
during the period in which
a master is being upgraded
or one master is unavailable,
your cluster control
plane remains available,
but technically speaking,
at that point in
time it's no longer
a high-availability control
plane, because if there was
a meteor strike on one of
the two remaining masters,
writes to the database
would no longer succeed.
So you can see from this example
that having an odd cluster size
doesn't change the number
needed to reach a majority,
but you gain extra
failure tolerance
by adding the extra member.
So you always want to
run an etch cluster
with an odd number of members.
So by running an etcd
cluster of size 3,
this means that
our control plane
is tolerant to the
failure of one machine,
and of course it makes
sense to spread these
across different locations.
So for the other control plane
components-- the controller
manager, the scheduler, as well
as the cluster auto-scaler,
these all have
their own elections,
but they operate in
active/passive mode.
So only the leader
is doing any work,
and it talks directly
to its local API
server on the same master.
There's also an add-on
manager leader election,
and this just follows the
elected controller manager
leader.
JEFF JOHNSON: So that's one
piece of the overall pie,
right, having a
highly-reliable control panel--
or, sorry, control plane--
panel's nice, too.
But the network is also
a key piece of that.
When we talk about high
availability and failover,
that often meets load balancing.
But when you're thinking
about load balancing,
it's important that piece
is it's own single point
of failure.
Load balancing on GCP is not
like a traditional HA proxy
machine, you know, backed maybe
by DNS Round Robin or something
like that.
GKE uses Network Load
Balancing, a product
that's available for
you to use on GCE.
That load balancing is backed
by a technology called Maglev.
Maglev, there's a lot of
excellent papers out there
that go into great
detail, but essentially it
is a non-proxying
load balancer that's
part of our
software-defined network,
and it's the same
technology backing
load balancing across lots
of products in Google.
So what this diagram
represents are
some of the fiber connections
between GCP's data centers.
So Google lays a lot of its
own cable across the sea,
and we run our network at
a pretty low utilization.
What that gives us is the
ability to do failover.
So let's say Godzilla pops
out somewhere in the middle
there and takes one
or two cables down.
We have headroom in the other
connections to send the data.
So we're ready to do
those sorts of failover.
That sort of
redundancy and headroom
is critical to have
network reliability.
TINA ZHANG: So we've
talked a little bit
about how the control
plane operates
in a high-availability scenario.
Let's delve into
a bit of what GKE
is doing for you under
the hood when we create
a regional cluster,
and by extension,
how you might go
about bootstrapping
a high-availability cluster
yourself, because after all,
Kubernetes is an open source
project, and many of our users
actually-- well, many
of our Kubernetes users
might choose to run their
own high-availability cluster
directly on Google Compute
Engine, or on-prem in a data
center.
So "Kubernetes the
Hard Way" by Kelsey
Hightower does outline
the steps of what
you would need to do to roll
your own high-availability
solution.
We're not going to go
into all of that today.
But there's also the Cluster
Lifecycle Special Interest
Group in the open source project
that have developed a cube ADM
tool that helps a lot with the
bootstrapping of the control
plane.
However, even with those
fantastic resources,
you still have to do a lot
of the higher-level setup
and configuration.
Importantly you'd
still need to bootstrap
your own high
availability etcd cluster.
And the steps are again pretty
well-documented by CoreOS,
who founded the etcd
Project, but they're still
fairly involved,
and they include
setting up additional firewall
rules and SSL certificates
between the etcd servers
for communication,
as well as setting up some
sort of high-availability proxy
in front.
And vital system pods
such as Cube DNS,
you'd also need to
set those up to use
auto-scaling and anti-affinity
rules to be distributed
across multiple
nodes, and Jeff is
going to describe that
a little bit later on.
But once you have
everything initialized,
managing etcd clusters can be a
significant complexity overhead
in itself.
And I think we in the
SRE team, and many others
in the Kubernetes
open source community
have found this
out the hard way.
So historically we've run
zonal GKE clusters-- so just
with one etcd replica.
We've had issues
due to etcd crash
looping after a restart due to a
bug in right ahead log reading.
There's also a bug in
the version of etcd
we were using where the database
size would become increasingly
bloated and de-fragmented.
And with regional clusters
we have the added complexity
of leader election.
So we had some
regional-specific etcd bugs
where the etcd-1 events were
not garbage collected properly,
and where you could have an
etcd member lagging behind
in database snapshots, so
not being fully caught up
with the rest of the cluster.
So what we also found was
that the steps involved
in fixing an etcd replica that's
part of a three-member cluster
is also a lot more involved than
just fixing one etcd replica.
etcd is also extremely
sensitive to disk I/O,
so in the open source
version of this talk
we always recommend
to not provision
the resources too
conservatively because when
etcd becomes overloaded you
really need that disk capacity.
But don't just take
our word for it.
As I mentioned, there's
a lot of KubeCon talks
on this topic from us
and also other people
managing their own clusters.
But with GKE the good news
is that the cluster creation
process happens behind the
scenes at a click of a button.
And once your cluster
is up and running,
your friendly SRE team are
responsible for managing
the control plane
components on your behalf.
JEFF JOHNSON: So now that you
have a little bit of background
on the top two layers
of the stack, what
you get from using GKE, let's
talk about the next two.
Let's talk about
your application
and the persistence.
A reliable Kubernetes
cluster is a table state
for high availability, but
it's not a silver bullet.
As an application
developer, it's
your responsibility to ensure
that your application is
deployed in a way that's
ready to handle failure.
Your persistence
should be resilient
to single-zone failure.
So on GCE-- or GKE or GCE, if
you're using persistent disks,
that means using
a regional disk,
and picking two zones to
do replication across.
I'll show how to
do that in a bit.
And if you're using
other data services
within GCP such as Cloud
SQL, you to make sure
that they're configured in a
highly available configuration
and support failover
your application
should be running in a mode
that is ready for failure.
So for instance, just like
the Kubernetes API server,
if you're running in
an active active mode,
That means that any
one of your instances
are ready to handle
traffic at any time.
This is a excellent pattern
for stateless applications.
And it's generally very easy to
just turn the replica knob up.
But it doesn't work for a lot of
other applications, especially
stateful applications.
So there are other patterns,
such as active passive,
you can utilize.
In an active passive mode--
much like our
controller manager--
you've got one instance
that is doing all the work
and a few that are
sort of sitting idly
by ready to be summoned.
That requires a lot
more orchestration.
And I'll show you how
you can sort of achieve
a little bit of that with
a little bit of downtime
by using Kubernetes.
So with all of that
background and a week
of hearing that word Kubernetes,
let's jump into a demo
where we actually
make some stuff fail.
So if you've ever seen
a Kubernetes demo,
no doubt you've
seen the Guestbook.
The Guestbook is a
bit of a toy app.
But it actually represents a lot
of common patterns seen in just
about every application.
So if you haven't
seen the Guestbook,
the Guestbook is like a ledger.
You can write a message.
Well, we've got
some saved there.
And it is persisted
through refreshes.
Good, it's working.
But to really understand
what's going on
and apply this to
your application,
we need to look at the services
that make up the application.
First, I will, of course,
reconnect to my GCEVM
so we can show you.
If you're interested in
looking at the Guestbook,
the Guestbook is in
the Kubernetes repo,
the main Kubernetes
repo under Examples.
And what I did was I took the
YAML that's deploying it today,
and I made a few tweaks
to support failover.
So let's look at how
it's deployed first.
So this is a bit of
an eye chart here.
So I apologize for that.
But I'll sort of walk you
through the groups here.
The top three nodes, the top
three pods are the front end.
That's a serverless web
application and a Docker
container.
It happens to be
a PHP application.
I'm throwing no shade on that.
That was my first
language besides English.
And if you look,
that far right column
in the Node section, those
are across two separate nodes.
The three instances are
across two separate nodes.
Those two separate nodes are
deployed to different zones.
So we have one of those
nodes in central 1c
and one in central 1f.
The next set of pods here
is the redis-follower.
The redis-follower is a
read-only copy of the database.
So the persistence
doesn't really matter.
It will get in sync with
the leader when we ask it,
when we query for it.
So whenever we do renders
of the Guestbook, whenever
we do views, we're going
to ask those databases what
the state of the world is.
But when we need
to do rights, we
want to talk to redis-leader.
Redis-leader is the
center of truth.
And that means that
its persistence
is really important.
If a zone went down and we
couldn't get the disk back
from that zone, well,
then essentially
our application is in a
state where it's not useful.
But a bonus that we get by
having those read-only replicas
running on separate nodes as
well is that if one of those
goes down, in the mean
time while the leader is
being rescheduled, we still have
a full copy of our database.
We can still do reads.
We may just have to wait a
little bit to do commits.
So let's take this thing down.
I want to make sure
we take down the one
with the redis-follower.
So let's do a little watch.
That follows on DG00, of course.
Sorry, leader.
And that is central 1c.
OK.
So fortunately for you,
I do not have the ability
to actually shut
down a GCE zone.
I could see where that would
be a concern as a customer.
But what I do have
is a Kubernetes API.
And what the API
lets me do is it
lets me mark a
node as unscheduled
and then immediately evict
all the workloads off of that.
If you're playing along at home,
you can run these same commands
there.
Drain is the one you want to
start evicting the workloads.
Or you could do a GCloud
compute instance delete.
The reason why I'm just
evicting them right here is
that it does take a
little bit of time
for that node to come down
and Kubernetes needs to go,
all right, it's time to
reschedule that work.
And that's because it's
also designed for failure.
It's going to have some
loops before it takes.
But we're in a demo, we
want to see action fast.
And while I blabbed
over that whole thing,
we can see the redis-leader
was rescheduled
it's been running now for 38
seconds some of our other pods
have been rescheduled.
And the ones that were
running on that healthy node
that we didn't mess with have
been running for three hours
when I woke up this morning.
And let's hope this
thing still works.
OK that's a good sign.
So this looks like a toy.
This is simple, but what
we've actually done here
is we've taken down
a machine in a zone.
And let's focus on
the redis-leader,
We took it down on a zone.
It had an attached disk.
That disk contained the
truth of our application.
We moved it to a new
machine in a different zone
that was happy.
We reattached that disk.
And it came up in a
short period of time.
Throughout that
time, our application
would have been accessible.
We would have been able to
ingress into our cluster.
While that red as leader
was being rescheduled,
we wouldn't have been
able to make rights.
But we can still keep
our page up and healthy.
And that's a tradeoff
that you need
to make when you're considering
your application deployment.
This, by the way,
isn't what you'll get
if you deploy the Guestbook.
If you go to Kubernetes
examples Guestbook,
that's not what you'll
get out of the box.
Let's look at some
of the changes
I made to make that work.
So let's look at the front end.
So the front end,
as I mentioned,
is a stateless application.
This is the YAML
section of the talk
so it might be
extra hard to see.
Oh yeah, doesn't get a
lot bigger than that.
So it is a Kubernetes
deployment with three replicas.
And that's where you say,
I've got a bunch of pods.
Run three copies of it.
Out of the box,
Kubernetes it doesn't
make any scheduling guarantees
about where those go so.
It could just as well
stick all those replicas
on the same node.
If you're on a high replica
account to handle failover,
that's really not
going to cut it.
That's just one
piece of the puzzle.
What you can do, though, is
you can hint at Kubernetes.
You can tell it what you want.
And if we look at
the bottom the way
I've done that is using
pod anti-affinity.
Pod anti-affinity
either tells or hints
at the scheduler to schedule
your pods in some way.
So if you dive down the
tree a little bit here,
we've specified the same
metadata, the same app
selector, app Guestbook
to your front end.
And we specified this failure
domain key, that being this
is zone key.
So this is where
you are starting
to think about what you
want your application
to be resilient to.
This could also be a machine.
And this will tell
Kubernetes, OK,
if a pod is already scheduled
on this zone or this machine,
try not to schedule
another one there.
The redis--follower is
deployed in the same way.
I'm not retaining its
persistence across,
because it is able to
catch itself up to speed.
We could try doing that,
and it should work.
But if you don't need to make
it that complex, don't, let
your testing and let your
evaluation of the reliability
inform those sort of decisions.
One thing I want to
point out, though,
is that we've used
prefer schedule.
You can tell
communities absolutely
do not schedule this node if
it meets these conditions.
But what would happen in
that failure scenario is
when we lost a zone,
sure, we'll move over
the work that can be moved
over like singletons.
But we're not going to
reschedule the nodes
that you'd expect.
We're not going to
say, OK, well let's
shift all these leaders over
here to this healthy zone.
So we won't actually be able
to serve the same capacity
that we could before.
It's important to
be aware of this
as you're planning
your deployment.
The most interesting one to
show off is the redis-leader.
The redis-leader is
deployed as a StatefulSet.
And I changed that from
being a deployment.
And what StatefulSet
allows us to do here
is specify a volume
claim template.
Volume claim template
says, OK, I need a disk.
And the disk has this sort of
storage class, just a name,
just to string
that I picked here.
And Kubernetes will
reliably attach this disk,
or attempt to attach
this disk too my node
and eventually to my pod.
So the volume mounting
is redis-data.
And it's in the slash data
directory of the container,
nothing crazy.
But the storage
class is something
that you're creating
in your planning.
So let's take a look at how
I define this storage class.
For the storage class, you
specify a name, a provisioner--
so I'm using a GCE
persistent disk--
and then the parameters
for that provisioner.
And the important
ones to look at today
are the replication type.
We're using a regional PD.
And then we're specifying two
zones for that regional PD
to replicate to.
So regional PDs allow us
to say, across these zones,
I want to make sure that my
data is always being replicated.
So if I do it right
here, it is always
available on this other zone.
These zones don't necessarily
need to coincide with your VM.
But for performance, it's
probably a good idea.
And when you think about
your exposure to failure,
it's probably a good idea
to be aware of that as well.
All right.
So now that we've seen a demo
in action, let's sort of review
some of those core
concepts and best practices
for your own application.
Back on the slides.
Thank you.
So regional clusters are
a piece of the puzzle
to handle zonal failures.
But they give you a lot
of everyday improvements,
like zero downtime
upgrades and resizes.
So something you
should be aware of.
If you resize your cluster
from one worker node to 100,
we're going to resize the master
node backing in our project.
Because there's a
lot more traffic,
a 100 nodes actually, 100x.
And in that scenario, because
we roll out changes one by one
in a regional cluster, you
shouldn't see a lot of downtime
in that.
That should be a
graceful failover.
As if GA, regional
clusters are free.
So there isn't really
a concern about cost
in terms of having a
bunch of master nodes.
But node locations
are really something
you should be aware of.
And a reason to be
aware of that is around
crosses zonal traffic.
So if you have an application
that is particularly latency
sensitive, that's doing a lot of
interest service communication,
you might be used to
that one millisecond
in the 95th percentile
timing, that sort of latency.
But it's going to be increased
it's going across zone.
Like Tina mentioned
earlier, think of it
as going out of one
building in the campus
and going to another.
Another concern is
cost of that traffic.
So when you're running
traffic within your zone,
you're not being
billed for that.
But when you cross
the zones, there
is billing associated with that.
So if you're doing
something like pulling down
a lot of database
results, if you're
doing something like
streaming a lot of log data,
that can add up.
And it's something you
should be aware of as you
plan your deployment.
Technologies like Istio,
like a service mash
can help you to sort of
inform these and plan these
out a little bit better.
A few things just to be aware of
that are really more edge cases
is that when you spread
across multiple zones,
you're exposing yourself
more to zonal issues.
The simple fact that
you're in more zones
means that you might be in that
unlucky asteroid strike, right?
Things like upgrades,
creates, and deletes
could be impacted by that.
It will certainly take more
time to roll those changes out,
because we do those one by
one instead of in one shot.
So if you have an
environment where
you're creating GKE
clusters very rapidly,
you should be aware
of that, something
like a CI environment.
If you're running a big
cluster, it's not a guarantee
that you can spin up 500
nodes immediately or 1,000
nodes immediately.
So you may run into quota
limits, for example.
So it's important to just like
your applications are reserving
for capacity and
failure that you also
have some node
capacity if that's
what you're designing for.
Now at the moment, you can't
migrate between a zonal cluster
and a regional cluster.
So it's a choice you
have to make upfront.
So with that
background the team is
going to talk to
you about how these
clusters healthy and reliable.
TINA ZHANG: OK thanks, Jeff.
Yeah, so we've demonstrated
how the GKE regional clusters
products can make your
GKE cluster mode reliable.
So well, how are
Google engineers
keeping their side
of the bargain
to help make the
GKE system reliable?
This is a challenge
for us, particularly
as the adoption in
GKE continues to grow,
as well as the number
of GCP locations.
So in SRE the team, we're
responsible for managing
the fleet of GKE hosted
masters and making sure
that the Kubernetes control
plane components are
up and running, as
well as managing
the upgrade cycle of the masters
and ultimately protecting
the service level objectives
to ensure a positive customer
experience for our users.
So we do this by holding
the pager for the product.
But we also help to work with
feature launches, the release
process, and general product
designs with our developer
partners, as well as
other teams within Google
that GKE is reliant on.
And we have teams in
Seattle and London
providing 24/7 on-call coverage.
And ultimately, the aim of all
site reliability engineering
teams is to automate
our own jobs away,
much in the same vein
as the Kubernetes
self-healing philosophy so that
the system can detect and heal
itself without
manual intervention.
And we do this by iterating
on pages and outages
to make sure that they
don't happen repeatedly.
So in order to do
this, we need to have
good observability
and strong insights
into the system behavior.
So we care both about the
GKE platform as well as
every single cluster.
We do this by gathering metrics
on both of those aspects
and visualizing
them on dashboards
using an internal Google version
that's been around for years,
used by all SRE teams.
But it's pretty
similar to how you
might use Promethus or
Grafana for metric gathering
and visualization in
your own clusters.
And we also keep an
aggregated view of this
so that we can see
fleet-wide differences
between cloud locations and
different Kubernetes versions.
And finally, we
have some probers
running outside of Google Cloud
Platform that are constantly
creating and deleting clusters.
So this helps to give us
a critical black box view
into what a user would see.
So in order to gather this
data in every cloud location
we have a job running outside
of GCP called the monitoring
server.
And this collects metrics,
metadata, and core component
logs from each master.
So our definition of
master availability
is based on Cube CTL
component states is returning
healthy for every component.
And if availability is down
for a short period of time,
the monitoring server
will automatically
recreate the unavailable
or unhealthy master VM.
And it can also resize
the master VM in order
to handle higher workloads.
And if these actions don't
work and the master continues
to remain unavailable,
an alert is sent
to your friendly on-caller.
This can also happen if
some other metrics get
into a bad state according to
some predefined conditions,
such as ET CD
backups being too old
or master of VM
disks being too full.
And depending on the
severity of the condition,
the alert can be either
a ticket or a page that
requires an immediate response.
And it might be
version-specific,
location-specific, or
even cluster-specific.
And we can also get tickets
from our front support team
if they're seeing
urgent customer issues.
And I think we're
pretty lucky in GKE
that so many Googlers are
contributors to the open source
project.
So when we do see issues
or bugs with an underlying
version of Kubernetes,
we can pretty easily
get those fixes in.
So a common workflow might be
an on-caller receives an alert.
We would then check our
dashboards and metrics
to see the vital
signs of the cluster,
look in the playbook for
mitigation and debugging tips.
These might include
some of the ET CD bugs
that I described earlier.
And then we typically use one of
the following common procedures
to mitigate against problems.
So rolling back or
rolling forward.
If it's a problem with
the GKE control plane,
that's pretty
straightforward as we have
full control of those jobs.
If it's a problem with an
underlying Kubernetes version,
it's a little bit trickier.
We would need to cut a release
with a fix and upstream it.
We can also upsize
or upgrade the master
if it's a
cluster-specific issue.
Typically, we'll try to give
the master a few more resources.
And in the case of
higher workloads,
that's pretty effective.
Sometimes we'll have
to tweak the alert.
If it's set too sensitively,
or if it fired in a way
that didn't make sense.
And this is part of iterating
on our alerts to make sure
that they're all actionable.
And finally, we
do sometimes have
to resort to silencing alerts.
We try to avoid this
as much as possible.
But sometimes, it's
down to an issue
that we can't take
direct action on.
So for example, if we need to
wait for the next open source
release, or if
it's an issue where
the customer has
to go into the card
console and fix the problem.
So we've talked a little
bit about the routine alerts
and routine mitigation actions.
But sometimes, a large
outage occurs, something
completely unexpected.
And there's a large
impact instant.
So what do we do
in those scenarios?
So in SRE we follow a mantra
of coordinate, communicate,
and control with an established
protocol in a crisis.
So on-callers are
encouraged to pull
in other members of their
team and get help and assign
defined roles.
So you have an
incident commander
who is managing and coordinating
efforts, an operations
lead and a communications lead.
So there are established
communications channels
that identify the impact
and notify our customers.
You may have seen some of
these on our Cloud page.
There's also escalation
pads to other parts of Cloud
and also our developers who
have their own on-call rotations
for various
subsystems within GKE
and Kubernetes that they
have more expertise on.
And after that instant,
it's really important
that we write a post mortem.
And even more importantly, we
learn from the action items
from the post-mortem
and execute on them
to make sure that the
instant is not repeated.
And sometimes, we
even share some
of these details
with our customers--
so the timeline of the instant
the root cause and the action
items that were taken.
So that's what we're
doing on our side
to improve the
resilience of the system.
To wrap up, as potential
regional cluster users,
what can you do to help improve
the resilience of your cluster
and also help us
not to get paged?
So in the open source
version of this talk
that I gave at CubeCon,
we talk about ensuring
that your ET CD backups
are done frequently
and that you also test the
restore from backup procedure
frequently as well.
But as I mentioned
before, in GKE,
this happens
automatically for you.
And similarly, if you're
running your own master,
I'd be advising that
you upgrade frequently
and keep on top of the
latest security fixes.
But again, this taken care for
you in our managed Kubernetes
product.
However as a GKE user, you
still have full control
over the upgrade
cycle of your nodes.
And we strongly recommend that
you enable node auto update
so we can keep it in sync
with the master version,
as well as node auto repair for
a fully self-healing cluster.
JEFF JOHNSON: We also recommend
that your provisioning
your project to have the
quota and capacities to handle
these multi-zonal workloads.
And something you can do to help
the Kubernetes scheduler out
is to provide resource
limits for your pods
and allow it to schedule those
a little bit more intelligently.
As an application
developer, it's
important that you're aware
of those high availability
scenarios.
High availability
masters, regional masters
do not make your workloads high
availability out of the box.
Spread your pods across
multiple zones in machines
using pod anti-affinity.
And ensure that you're using
regional storage and data
services.
So we thank you all for
joining us in this talk
and learning about GKE.
In the interest of
time, Tina and I
are going to have to
give up this room.
But we're going to
be available outside
to answer any questions
you might have.
And otherwise, please
enjoy the rest of the day.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]